[Music]
meet Lucy she was a math major in
college and aced all her courses in
probability and statistics which do you
think is more likely that Lucy is a
portrait artist or that Lucy is a
portrait artist who also plays poker in
studies of similar questions up to
eighty percent of participants chose the
equivalent of the second statement that
Lucy is a portrait artist who also plays
poker after all nothing we know about
Lucy suggests an affinity for art but
statistics and probability are useful in
poker and yet this is the wrong answer
look at the options again how do we know
the first statement is more likely to be
true because it's a less specific
version of the second statement saying
that Lucy is a portrait artist doesn't
make any claims about what else she
might or might not do but even though
it's far easier to imagine her playing
poker than making art based on the
background information the second
statement is only true if she does both
of these things however counterintuitive
it seems to imagine Lucy as an artist
the second scenario adds another
condition on top of that making it less
likely for any possible set of events
the likelihood of a occurring will
always be greater than the likelihood of
a and B both occurring if we took a
random sample of a million people who
majored in math the subsets who are
portrait artists might be relatively
small but it will necessarily be bigger
than the subsets who are portrait
artists and play poker
anyone who belongs to the second group
will also belong to the first but not
vice versa the more conditions there are
the less likely an event becomes so why
do statements with more conditions
sometimes seem more believable this is a
phenomenon known as the conjunction
fallacy when we're asked to make quick
decisions we tend to look for shortcuts
in this case we look for what seems
plausible rather than what is
statistically most probable on its own
loose
being an artist doesn't match the
expectations formed by the preceding
information the additional detail about
her playing poker gives us a narrative
that resonates with our intuitions it
makes it seem more plausible and we
choose the option that seems more
representative of the overall picture
regardless of its actual probability
this effect has been observed across
multiple studies including ones with
participants who understood statistics
well from students betting on sequences
of dice rolls to foreign policy experts
predicting the likelihood of a
diplomatic crisis the conjunction
fallacy isn't just a problem in
hypothetical situations conspiracy
theories and false news stories often
rely on a version of the conjunction
fallacy to seem credible the more
resonant details are added to an
outlandish story the more plausible it
begins to see but ultimately the
likelihood a story is true can never be
greater than the probability that it's
least likely component is true much of
our society relies on majority vote and
consensus so it's natural to think that
the more consensus the better but how
much trust should we place in unanimous
decisions check out this video on the
paradox of unanimity
[Music]